[музыка]
Вы прикладываете усилия, но каждый раз
это происходит как в первый раз. Вам
снова и снова приходится решать одни и
те же проблемы и делать одно и то же. Вы
начинаете что-то делать, но потом быстро
бросаете, потому что кажется, что это не
работает. Вы смотрите на успешных людей
и думаете, что у них есть какой-то
секрет. Секрет недоступный вам. На самом
деле всё это происходит потому, что вы
не понимаете одного из самых мощных
инструментов Вселенной, накопительного
эффекта. Именно накопительный эффект
определяет, почему у одних людей
результаты становятся всё круче и круче,
а у других, несмотря на все их усилия,
результаты остаются на том же уровне.
Альберт Эйнштейн назвал накопительный
эффект восьмым чудом света. Вы знаете,
что один из самых богатейших людей
планеты Урен Buffet более 90% своего
состояния заработал после 56 лет он
начал инвестировать в 11 лет. И до 56
лет он накопил только 1% своего
нынешнего богатства. А после пяше он
заработал более 160 млрд долларов. Как
это возможно, спросите вы. Это сила
сложного процента или накопительного
эффекта. Все мы с детства слышали
историю о том, как капля камень точит,
как черепаха обгоняет зайца, как
маленькие шаги приводят к большим
результатом. Но мало кто по-настоящему
понимает, как работает этот принцип в
реальной жизни. Мы живём в мире, где нас
окружают истории о мгновенном успехе, о
чудесных превращениях и волшебных
таблетках. Мы видим результаты, но не
видим самого процесса, который к ним
привёл. Мы с первого дня жизни наблюдаем
проявление накопительного эффекта. Мы
видим, как ребёнок растёт каждый день,
как деревья становятся выше года от
года, как знания накапливаются урок за
уроком. Но почему-то, когда дело
касается наших собственных целей, мы
забываем об этом принципе и ждём
мгновенных результатов. Так, что же
такое накопительный эффект?
Накопительный эффект - это явление, при
котором небольшие и регулярные действия,
усилия или ваши вложения со временем
складываются и приводят к значительным
результатам или изменениям в вашей
жизни. Благодаря тому, что каждый новый
результат строится на основе предыдущих,
создавая экспоненциональный рост вместо
линейного. Если сказать по-простому, то
накопительный эффект - это то, что
превращает ваши маленькие незаметные
шаги в огромные достижения. благодаря
тому, что каждый
результат усиливает либо облегчает
следующий. Вот представьте себе
маленький снежный комочек на вершине
горы. Так вот, когда вы толкаете его, он
начинает катиться вниз, постепенно
налепляя на себя и собирая всё больше и
больше снега. Сначала, конечно, рост
незаметен, он такой комочек становится
чуть больше, потом ещё чуть больше, но с
каждым оборотом его поверхность
увеличивается, и это позволяет ему
захватывать ещё больше снега. И к
подножию горы маленький комочек
превращается в огромный снежный валун
или даже в снежную лавину. Важно то, что
большая часть роста происходит не в
начале пути, а ближе к концу, когда
накопленная масса начинает расти
геометрически. А как же тогда истории о
мгновенном успехе, спросите вы? Неужели
это всё ложь? Конечно же, нет. Но то,
что вам кажется мгновенным успехом, на
самом деле почти всегда является
результатом долгого накопления. Просто
мы видим только момент прорыва, конечную
картинку, но мы не видим всех тех
маленьких шагов, которые человек делал
ежедневно. Сегодня мы и поговорим о том,
что такое накопительный эффект, как он
работает в разных сферах жизни и как его
использовать для достижения своих целей.
Этот ролик - продолжение цикла моих
видео о суперпозиции. Сразу хотел бы
предупредить, что этот ролик не будет
полезен тем, кто хочет всё и сразу,
желательно, причём без труда. Данный
ролик для тех, кто не верит в сказки и
байки и понимает, что за каждым везением
и за каждым крупным успехом кроется
ежедневный невидимый и кропотливый труд.
Не ждите, что я дам вам секретный
секрет, как достичь всего, не делая
ничего. Ролик будет полезен всем, кто
хочет понять, как сделать так, чтобы
твои прошлые успехи или усилия не
обнулялись, а помогали тебе достигать
большего с наименьшими усилиями. По
сути, как сделать так, чтобы твоё
прошлое работало на твоё будущее.
Сегодня мы поймём, что успех - это не
событие, а процесс. Что терпение и
постоянство - это не не просто красивые
слова, а реальные инструменты достижения
целей. Поняв концепцию накопительного
эффекта, вы увидите, что для достижения
больших результатов не всегда нужны
сверхъестественные способности и
прорывы. Нужно лишь понимание того, как
работает накопительный эффект и
готовность использовать его в своей
жизни. Накопительный эффект не отменяет
закономерного везения, о котором мы
говорили в прошлых видео. Накопительный
эффект - это просто ещё один инструмент
суперпозиции, который говорит о том, как
создать такую ситуацию, при которой тебе
закономерно везёт. И весь мир хочет,
чтобы ты добивался своих
целей. Для начала давайте поймём, что
такое накопительный эффект и как он
работает. Накопительный эффект - это
явление, при котором небольшие
регулярные действия или усилия, ну или
вложения со временем складываются и
приводят к значительным результатам или
изменениям. Видите, это простое
определение, но за ним скрывается
огромная сила. Накопительный эффект -
это то, что превращает ваши маленькие
шаги в большие достижения. Он позволяет
вам достичь значительных результатов без
необходимости совершать героические
усилия. Вместо того, чтобы пытаться
сделать что-то грандиозное одним махом,
вы можете сделать маленькие шаги, но
каждый день, и со временем эти шаги
приведут вас к большой цели.
Накопительный эффект - это, в принципе,
не новая концепция. Народная мудрость
веками отражала этот принцип в
пословицах и поговорках. Ну давайте,
например, копейка рубль бережёт. Эта
пословица подчёркивает, что маленькие
сбережения или экономия могут со
временем превратиться в значительную
сумму или терпение и труд всё перетруд.
Эта поговорка говорит о том, что
настойчивость и постоянные усилия рано
или поздно принесут свои плоды. Капля
камень точит. Данная пословица
подчёркивает силу накопительного
эффекта, когда даже маленькие действия,
повторяющиеся со временем и регулярно,
могут привести к значительным
изменениям. Дорогу осилит идущий. Это
выражение подчёркивает, что только
постоянное движение вперёд шаг за шагом
помогает достичь
целей. Москва не сразу строилась,
напоминает нам о том, что большие
достижения требуют времени и постоянных
усилий. Или, как говорится в кайзен
философии, быстро это медленно, но без
перерывов. Накопительный эффект работает
во всех сферах жизни. Давайте рассмотрим
несколько примеров из жизни. Здоровье и
фитнесы. Одна тренировка не сделает вас
атлетом, но регулярные тренировки в
течение года полностью преобразят ваше
тело. Так же, как одно яблоко не сделает
вас здоровым, но здоровое питание каждый
день в течение года значительно улучшит
ваше здоровье в образовании и навыках.
Один час изучения иностранного языка не
сделает вас
полиглотом, но ежедневная практика в
течение года позволит вам свободно
общаться на этом
языке. Так же как одна прочитанная книга
не сделает вас экспертом. Но чтение книг
каждый день в течение года даст вам
глубокие знания в выбранных
областях. Возьмём финансы. Одно
небольшое вложение не сделает вас
богатым, но регулярные инвестиции в
течение многих лет помогут привести вас
к значительному капиталу благодаря
сложным процентам. Одна сэкономленная
сумма не изменит ваше финансовое
положение, но привычка экономить и
разумно тратить деньги каждый день
приведёт к финансовой стабильности. Для
примера, если вы будете ежемесячно
инвестировать хотя бы по 10.000 тенге,
под 7% годовых, то через 30 лет ваш
капитал составит около
12.253.000 тенги, из которых только
3.600.000 ваши, а остальные
8.653.000. Это работа сложных процентов.
В личных привычках и саморазвитии один
день продуктивной работы не сделает вас
успешным, но привычка, эффективно
используя своё время каждый день,
приведёт к значительным
достижениям. Как же работает
накопительный эффект? Все вы наверняка
видели, как взлетает ракета. Заметили,
как она тяжело
отрывается от земли? Она буквально так с
трудом начинает набирать высоту. Так
вот, космическая ракета представляет
собой из один из самых наглядных
примеров преодоления барьера перед
получением накопительного эффекта.
Смотрите, когда ракета стартует с земле,
она сжигает
85-90% всего своего топлива лишь для
того, чтобы преодолеть первые 100-160 км
и выйти на орбиту. Это происходит из-за
того, что ей приходится бороться и с
гравитацией Земли, и с сопротивлением
атмосферы. Первые несколько минут полёта
кажутся крайне неэффективными. Огромное
количество топлива сжигается, а прогресс
в виде набранной высоты и скорости
выглядит минимальным. Однако после
преодоление начального барьера
происходит качественное изменение или
качественный скачок в результатах.
Теперь каждый килограмм оставшегося
топлива даёт несоизмеримо больший
эффект, и оставшиеся 10-15% топлива
могут использоваться для манёвров на
орбите или полётов в течение месяцев или
даже лет. Ракета может перемещаться на
огромное расстояние с минимальными
затратами энергии. Это и есть сила или
эффект накопленных усилий. Возьмём
другой, более простой пример,
показывающий, как накопительный эффект
работает на бытовом уровне. Ну,
допустим, вы решаете куда-то пойти или
что-то сделать. Вы делаете первый шаг,
который даётся вам нелегко. Для этого
вам нужно сначала перенести центр
тяжести вперёд, потом вам нужно вынести
ногу и сделать второй шаг. Но третий или
четвёртый шаг даётся вам гораздо легче.
Почему? Потому что вы набрали уже
инерцию и перенесли свой центр тяжести.
Видите, даже в бытовых ежедневных вещах
скрыт накопительный эффект. Приведу ещё
один пример. Эффект возрастающего
домино. Вот представьте себе домино, где
каждая следующая костяшка в полтора раза
выше, чем предыдущая. Так вот, если
первая костяшка будет всего лишь 5 см,
например, то двадцать третья костяшка
будет высотой сейфелеву башню, а
пятьдесят седьмая будет равна расстоянию
от Земли до Луны. С 5 см начали, а
пятьдесят седьмая уже расстояние от
Земли до Луны. Давайте возьмём примеры
из бизнеса. Сначала вы инвестируете
огромное количество ресурсов своего
времени, денег, усилий, получая при этом
минимальную отдачу. Большая часть
топлива или вашей энергии уходит на
преодоление начального сопротивления и
создания фундамента. Но после достижения
определённой критической массы
происходит качественный скачок.
Дальнейшее движение становится в разы
эффективнее, и те же самые усилия
приносят вам многократно больший
результат. Как и с ракетой, самая
сложная часть пути - это начало. Но
после преодоления барьера, барьера
начальных трудностей, накопительный
эффект начинает работать на вас,
позволяя вам достигать грандиозных
результатов с гораздо меньшими
затратами. То же самое, в принципе,
происходит и с любыми нашими усилиями.
Сначала результаты могут быть
незаметными, и может даже казаться, что
мы топчимся на месте. Но если мы
продолжим делать правильные действия
регулярно, то со временем результаты
начинают накапливаться, и в какой-то
момент происходит прорыв. Накопительный
эффект имеет несколько важных
характеристик. Первое, прогрессия во
времени. Чем дольше вы что-то делаете,
тем значительнее становится результат.
Это как снежный ком, который становится
всё больше и больше, когда он катится с
горы. Или, как однажды хорошо сказал
Джеки Чан, успешным стать легко. Просто
долго занимайтесь одним делом. Заметили
здесь нюанс? Долго заниматься одним
делом. А что делает большинство людей?
Они мечутся постоянно меняют сферы
деятельности, постоянно ищут, где бы
заработать, вместо того, чтобы долго
совершенствоваться в одном. Вторая
характеристика - это малые действия,
совершаемые регулярно. Даже самые
маленькие действия, если их делать
регулярно, могут привести вас к
значительным результатам. Это вот как
капля воды, которая точит камень не
силой, а частотой и регулярностью
падения. Третья характеристика - это
постепенность. Накопление происходит
постепенно, без резких скачков. Это,
конечно же, требует терпения и
устойчивости. Как говорится, тише едешь,
дальше будешь. Недаром в исламе
говорится, что Аллах даёт баракат или
благо за две вещи. Это за риск и за
терпение. Четвёртая характеристика - это
эффект синергии. Когда регулярные
маленькие действия объединяются, они
создают результат, который больше, чем
сумма их отдельных частей. Это вот как и
ингредиенты в рецепте, которые вместе
создают блюдо, вкус которого превосходит
вкус каждого ингредиента по отдельности.
Пятая характеристика - это
инерционность. После достижения
определённой точки накопительный эффект
начинает работать сам по себе. Даже если
вы снижаете усилия, это вот как
велосипед, который продолжает ехать,
даже если вы перестаёте крутить педали.
Почему же многие люди не используют
накопительный эффект? Основная проблема
в том, что мы живём в мире мгновенного
удовлетворения. Мы хотим видеть
результаты сразу, не через месяцы или
годы, а сразу. Мы начинаем что-то
делать, не видим быстрых результатов и
бросаем, не дождавшись, когда
накопительный эффект начнёт работать.
Кроме того, мы часто недооцениваем силу
маленьких действий. Нам кажется, что
чтобы достичь больших результатов, нужно
сделать что-то грандиозное. Но на
самом-то деле маленькие, но регулярные
действия часто приводят к большим
результатам, чем редкие героические
усилия. Как же использовать
накопительный эффект в своей жизни?
Первое, самое важное - это выбрать
правильные действия или правильное
направление. Имейте в виду, не все
действия приводят к положительному
накопительному эффекту. Некоторые
действия могут даже иметь отрицательный
накопительный эффект. Например,
ежедневное употребление фастфуда или
курение сигарет будет накапливать
проблемы со здоровьем. Поэтому важно
выбирать действия, которые приведут вас
к желаемым результатам. Второе. Будьте
последовательны. Регулярность - ключ к
накопительному эффекту. Лучше делать
что-то маленькое каждый день, чем что-то
большое раз в месяц или в год. Как
говорится, капля камень точит. Третье.
Будьте
терпеливы. Накопительный эффект требует
времени. Не ждите мгновенных
результатов. Помните, что большие
достижения складываются из маленьких
шагов. Четвёртое. Используйте силу
привычек. Ну, это мой самый любимый
конёк. Привычки - это автоматические
действия, которые мы выполняем без
сознательного усилия. Если вы сможете
превратить полезные действия в привычки,
то накопительный эффект будет работать
на вас
автоматически. Давайте подытожим.
Первое. Накопительный эффект - это
явление, при котором небольшие, но
регулярные действия, усилия или вложения
со временем складываются и приводят к
значительным результатам или изменениям.
Второе. Для того, чтобы использовать
накопительный эффект, нужно выбрать
правильные действия, быть
последовательным, терпеливым и
использовать силу привычек. Третье.
Накопительный эффект работает во всех
сферах жизни: здоровье, в фитнесе, в
образовании, в навыках, в финансах, в
личных привычках и саморазвитии, в
бизнесе и
инвестициях. Помните, большие достижения
складываются из маленьких шагов,
сделанных с течением времени. Не ждите
мгновенных результатов. Будьте терпеливы
и последовательны, и накопительный
эффект будет работать на вас. Как
говорится, дорога в тыщули начинается с
первого шага. Сделайте этот первый шаг
сегодня и продолжайте делать маленькие
шаги каждый день. И через некоторое
время вы удивитесь, как далеко вы
продвинулись. Ну а я на этом с вами
прощаюсь. Желаю вам не терять того, чего
вы достигли, и добиться эффекта, когда
ваши прошлые усилия облегчают вам ваше
будущее. До новых встреч.
[музыка]